[Music]
the national library of medicine spent
four years collecting native people
stories about health and illness from
all over the country
now the nlm is returning to the
communities that contributed their
stories
by way of a traveling version of the
native voices
native people's concepts of health and
illness exhibition
the spirit lake nation was the first
stop on a nationwide tour that will
include
indian reservations native health and
cultural centers
and regional medical libraries
over 150 native people were interviewed
for this exhibit
from across indian country including
native hawaiians
this includes tribal leaders tribal
elders
spiritual people medicine people it's a
wonderful show and this morning we're
going to be opening
the native voices exhibit
an indian country in alaska and hawaii
we found that all three peoples
have much to teach us about health and
prevention of illness and managing life
so we put together the exhibition really
to make public
some of the good ideas and some of the
good accomplishments in native american
peoples and
to be shared amongst them and also in
the general population
the traveling version is smaller in size
than the native voices exhibition at the
national library of medicine in bethesda
but it contains all of the video
interviews of the original
presented on ipads with accompanying
banners
i think it's important for us as native
people to finally
speak out and be heard so i think it's a
great opportunity for many of us to
share our stories because we have a lot
of stories that need to be shared
the native voices traveling exhibition
displays personal stories from tribal
leaders
healers and native physicians who can
serve as role models for young people
living on reservations
the only sort of hidden agenda item for
me
is that i wish that we could all do
something to encourage
more native americans in healthcare
medical professions it has to start
early lift your eyes let your goals be
high
i think that this tribal college is
trying to do exactly that
chandeska chistana community college is
the home college of the spirit lake
tribe in fort totten
north dakota under the leadership of
college president dr cynthia lindquist
the college has evolved from purely
vocational studies
to more academically oriented programs
my grandmother elvina alberts was very
instrumental in starting the college
she said the tatanka used to be our food
meaning buffalo
but now she said the tatanka is through
education and that's what we have to go
after
the native voices traveling exhibition
provides an opportunity for local
communities to showcase their own
traditions
and cultural offerings
the grand opening at chandeska chistina
was the finale to a week of healing
events at the college
healers traveled from all over the
dakotas to participate in panel
discussions
and students enjoyed movies featuring
native american actors
the north dakota museum of arts songs
for spirit lake exhibit was displayed on
the campus where it landed after a
successful run in new york city
in songs for spirit lake six artists
explore how people live within the
landscape
who the people are and how they join the
past and present
in life today three
two nina mata
i am proud my name is jada lanzi
members of the spirit lake community
contributed their own stories to the
week of festivities
through a companion digital storytelling
program produced by indigenes
i think a lot of the stories that that
we
tend to hear about ourselves we tend to
memorialize the past
and this is really celebrating the
present that we're still here
we're still alive we're still
doing what has been taught us what has
been given to us through our
culture following the north dakota
launch
native voices will travel to sites in
hawaii alaska
seattle and oklahoma and then to
additional sites nationwide
[Music]
i think it's wonderful because the
indian people whatever reason never
really talk about things
and i think it's really important that
we leave our history with whoever we can
with our for our children our
grandchildren and i think of anything
that can bring indian country
closer together
[Music]
you